what do I look like wearing the scarf I
don't know what every Canadian ever cool
macchiatos good man it's like almost as
good as what you could get in like a
smaller American city like Portland or
Minneapolis says it's kind of cool you
guys have like a mayor of big major city
who smokes crack now yeah we had one of
those 20 years ago say it boot
what hey hoser call me house or me
computer about at first about a boot see
your vision bag away what say dude in
the boot sit in the boot I was in the
boot laughing heads your butyl eyes when
did you guys get iPhones you guys have
childish gambino up here hey you guys
are the wolf song yeah
let us don't get hit like it's the
biggest most important city in the
country and no one else likes it
everyone in Canada bigs Toronto is a
garbage dump drake started from the
bottom you know the bottom is toronto
the huh Canadians don't have sweet games
like this they'll show me how you dance
boy
so exactly how long ago did you guys
stop being England [ __ ] what are you
looking for over there national identity
ryan gosling scream good book I'll
believe that Will Arnett is definitely
not Canadian yeah
we'll Annette is Canadian we will own
this Canadian way I know Seth Rogen is
not Canadian is I'm Seth Rogen there's
no way the kids in the hall or from
Canada in Chicago it's Chicago how is
the guy in charge
the guy at 70% of the country voted
against what an opposition party's just
form a coalition power share and Houston
can they do that is there has there ever
been like a talented comedian who didn't
move to the states saying McGill is the
Harvard of Canada is like saying Rush is
the Rolling Stones of Canada it's
technically true but also incredibly
illustrative Quebec is great Quebec is
probably the best thing about Canada and
it wants nothing to do with you
ultimately like is that really the thing
that hang your hat on
do we really give a [ __ ] about navel
syrup and maple syrup just disappeared
forever would your life be impacted in a
serious way at all I wish you
disappeared forever
on the real go I love Canada it's a
great country
I'd enjoy here it's quaint don't enjoy
you I'm not in charge these videos never
gonna go anywhere just so I can be mean
to scatter like a looking at sage
countries garbage